[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Tuesday we're
nowhere
welcome to know where we are in the
Sahara Desert thirsting quenching for
some good news and there is none except
for the fact that the morning chess is
on happy happy Tuesday everyone welcome
back to the morning toast yes what a
slow-ass week yesterday was the longest
day of life like this diversion that was
not divine well has thrown off my whole
week like things will be okay until next
Monday so see you then I'm just really
looking forward well today's a actually
this week is weird for me because I'm on
the toast tomorrow but then I'm heading
to Portland for my show in Portland and
then Seattle and Vancouver tickets
available all girl from top calm um so
I'm out Wednesday to Monday but I'm
gonna do show Wednesday Thursday is
gonna be Nick viola it's couple of a
scene oh yes Nick bio Friday Margo and I
will be doing an episodes from wherever
the hell we're gonna be and then Monday
it's gonna be a bunch on the Cho
situation
hopefully he remembers yeah he said he
was like you please remind me Sunday I'm
like oh yeah sure I'm I just said a
[ __ ] alarm on your phone right right
or just remember try out or just shy of
or just remember no that's not an option
for some thanks Monday everybody on the
- I understand him not remembering like
as a queen who can't remember things I
totally relate but it's a great damn bro
but like you put in forget like an
appearance on the most popular money a
morning show you wouldn't forget - I
would if there wasn't looking at
follow-up email or anything you wouldn't
forget it I think I would know it's like
it is like your wife especially if you
had like a merged shop the next day like
yeah I mean I don't uh I don't hold him
like hostage because he forgot I'm upset
him for not writing it down and putting
in this phone like that's what a normal
as responsible adult would do we can't
help if we forget things yeah I guess um
well welcome back to the morning show so
obviously today we are going to be
ending in with the past my stories
before that certain thing you guys want
to chat about we're gonna be recapping a
bunch of shows at the end of this
episode mean Marco both watch Dancing
with the Stars I finally watched tall
girl okay
- and was an O and blow deck I wait a
mite will attack I was having a hallmark
evening this is actually the time of
year where I start to get like FOMO not
FOMO but it's like I watched hallmark
instead of watching like what's trending
so I missed the roast
I missed Dancing with the Stars because
I've listened to this cable moments yeah
because I'm choosing hallmark over
everything and then like I am just not a
part of the conversation and it gives me
anxiety that like I'm not doing my
homework that happens to me seasonally
as well but just like with friends but I
just cannot bother to change it input
and go to cable yes so like I'm I feel
bad but I don't like a hallmark over
everything it's just having this new
hallmark app has really changed my life
for the better so it's almost like
Taylor Swift watches the toast and
notice about the choice because she
knows that I'm literally busy starting
at 10:30 a.m. and as this show was going
live she put up an Instagram and that
Instagram was a bunch of announcements
about some festival and now I need to
get tickets and it's like I'm just
sitting here and I can't Berger what is
instruments okay so she's doing a lover
fast basically making her own festival
oh that's cool and it's a bunch of dates
only for in the US - a - in LA - in
Foxborough Gillette Stadium what what
time of year summer caption for me the
lover album is open fields and sunsets
and summer I want to celebrate the album
perform it live with you in a way that
feels authentic to the music I want to
go to some places that haven't been and
play festivals for the first time in
ages and where we didn't have festivals
we made some well saying lover fests
east and west details and additional
dates coming soon additional dates
coming soon maybe she'll do my wife did
you think this is instead of a tour um I
don't I don't know I feel like this
might just be her building a tour I
think this is instead of a tour I kind
of think so too I can't I just think she
can do it on top of this considering she
hasn't liked touring but you know she
doesn't not like touring but what she
said in her press interviews was like I
can't have my life be released an album
go on tour released an album go on tour
like that type of lifestyle is like so
toxic so I understand her not wanting to
go on tour for a bit but now she's doing
like an alternative vibe for a stadium
tour I think this is kind of cool but
she's gonna need more than four [ __ ]
days it's she said stay tuned for
additional dates and more details that's
pretty cool wait til festivals that
already existed so in the one in LA is
that let's go so the ones who ever fest
west yes and new ones in u.s. gonna be
performing like is there a lineup or
it's just too
she's just like making her own like
Shawn Mendes Haim Kibeho
it's not a festival if it's just like if
you were performing that's a concert
right I guess she would make it like a
full-day experience maybe she would
perform like a different parts of the
day she would have to get other
performers and she probably will or she
would have to make it like more than a
three-hour concert like I'd have to be
like 1/8 average that's actually a
really good idea yeah like she could
make it a festival Ferris like
activities and things for people to do
but it's still in a stadium so it's
still gonna be Stadium food oh right I
forgot right but it could be like how
like Wango Tango is in a stadium and I
know if I go to those in like an
amphitheater no but like Wango Tango in
a stadium but yeah it's just a long
concert with a lot of different musical
acts main 40 so where's the LA location
does it say yes it's zombie Stadium
Sofie Stadium I guess it's like the Rams
Stadium so stadiums interesting I don't
understand that studio I love a stadium
a festival stadium right we went to
Billboard Hot 100 it was a festival in
the stadium and at Jones Beach and it
was them nobody was tortured remember
like honestly there's not other [ __ ]
before worse than out left and right
I was one of them campers down counters
down like I hope if none of the
performers honestly I don't need to
waste my time with some trash I came
here to see Taylor there should like but
she has openers on her tour so there'll
be at least two other performers that
contributes to the vibe if you're coming
all the way to Gillette Stadium like you
need to make a day of it know if we
won't obey the jokes say they don't want
to see my girl and get the [ __ ] out so I
can get home on the unday you know the
ten o'clock Amtrak but most people
aren't like that like if they're gonna
travel for a festival like you have to
give more than just wait it says
additional UK and international dates
and festivals would be announced soon so
it's only for American once why are we
getting shafted I don't know I think
because over the years of her touring
like everyone else but America has
gotten chaptered like she's done like 50
US shows and then like five random
European countries like maybe this is
her making it up to the International
stand-up which would be nice but kind of
annoying regardless I'm think I'm gonna
go to one of each and West
oh let's move out or we should go to
both to let's maybe maybe get a room we
got it had it like I don't understand
how to get I want to hear more about the
about gonna go they love our concert
that's being built differently and I
have to go to
I did instead of MetLife like that's
frustrating but then it's kind of like
you're weeding out like the Fairweather
fans like if she's making people from
all around the country either go to two
locations like the people who shop are
true [ __ ] fans and like it really
will be a love fest that's true that's
an interesting we won't be able to get
tickets oh my god I now yeah Wow
interesting people you know constantly
evolving changing the game yeah I look
forward to seeing what this turns into I
like that she's thinking out of the box
me too me too me too because I'm not
here for album tour album tour hello and
this time he needs to get Ariana Grande
off the train yeah this way it's also in
the summer so she has a year off with
her new album before she has to like
start traveling again yeah good for her
good for her for you um rooms are over
grand already ones like hotel rooms you
may get Ross in we gotta go to Gurney's
Newport that's look Sophie even more
from July yes New England new looks
pretty large yeah yeah Margo just
reserved a room I like the W Boston or
something do it right the second yeah
you said they're going up that's just
based off of someone I can't find that
Farnam hands sorry August 2020 no I know
like I could be August first it's in
forever
it's a year from now yeah that's not how
I roll that's not how we roll we're just
gonna have to hope to get some tickets
on StubHub oh my god well you wouldn't
help us cuz you work there right and
maybe we have some friends in Boston who
are willing to help us the boss scenes
number one how gets in Boston that has
to count for something at Gillette
Stadium um it does I think it does that
that means by osmosis that someone that
works at Stadium is probably a big
[ __ ] toaster mmm maybe um Jackie and I
have to dive into the past five because
we've big meetings after this big oh
yeah money moves and it's all about the
new merch drop which is coming very soon
so he wanted to give you guys a little
bit of a heads up if you wanted to you
know allocate some funds to start
thinking about you know mood boarding
numerous will be coming very soon well
we don't have an exact date I would say
within the next two weeks yeah we'll get
that date to you soon yeah that's my
table if you're wondering why this merch
shop is taking so much longer it's
because it's brand new like it is it is
[ __ ] like you've never seen it though
okay it is new items new she
it's new everything and the biggest
reason why it's taking so long is that
our shipping time is about to be cut and
like you use stuff to wither ain't
really two weeks now to be about three
days so so yeah so just bear with us
we're getting our [ __ ] together we're
building a brand so you know this things
take time
yeah but not too much I'm just like spit
all over my we hear you it's gonna be
good stuff man like yeah Dori yeah we
hear you we see you we are you but
without further ado it is time for the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast also it's
important to note that while all these
crazy things are happening for our merch
the pricing will not really be going up
yet that's important to say um and bring
you thirsty [ __ ] it's time to let you
know that today's episode is brought to
you by liquid IV the fastest and most
efficient way to stay hydrated if you're
trying to drink more water like what IV
hydrates you two to three times faster
and more efficiently than water alone
with an added bonus of vitamin C b3 b5
b6 and b12 liquid IV helps prevent jet
lag when traveling its TSA friendly and
it's perfect for on-the-go travelers it
helps to keep your skin hydrated while
flying it can be the perfect for before
during or after flights submerged
dehydration is staying properly hydrated
in one of the most important factors
during the hot summer months perfect way
to stay hydrated while spending more
time outdoors liquid IV is the
fastest-growing wellness brand you can
find them anywhere even at Costco you
can find their hydration multipliers
hold at Costco's nationwide they're
convenient TSA friendly powder packets
for travel helps prevent jet lag
altitude sickness and more we love
liquid IV we take them with them with us
everywhere we travel it's great for life
that's how I keep my skin glowing on
stage also a little bit of sweat we know
you would love it too right now our
listeners can get 25% off at liquid IV
calm when you use our code toast at
checkout
that's a 25% off anything you order on
liquid IV's website go to liquid IV
dot-com and enter our promo code toast
to get your savings and start getting
hydrated that's liquid IV dot-com promo
code toast don't wait to start properly
hydrating today there's no time like the
present so try to give yourself the gift
of liquid ID okay first story
what's sweeping the nation new SNL star
shine Gillis has been fired after making
racial slurs in a resurfaced video ok
this has been playing out over the past
few days SNL announced three new cast
members one of whom
was you know old tweet not tweets
c-calm podcast it's left him on this
podcast it was like a video podcast I
know some journalists dug it up right
and actually Emily you think it needs to
be dug like it wasn't so long ago which
makes this story even crazier because
SNL has now fired him and saying that
they did not they had not seen these
things which means they didn't do even
the slightest bit of research right but
it's like 2019 so I don't understand
like The Bachelor does more vetting then
and so then Shane released a statement
yes Twitter so new SNL cast member
shingles has officially been fired from
the series days after an online video
resurfaced depicting Gillis making a
racial slur the NBC sketch comedy series
announced on Monday that it has parted
ways with the comedian quote after
talking with Shane Gillis we decided
that he will not be joining us in Alice
an SNL spokesperson said in a statement
on behalf of Lorne Michaels what we want
nothing else have a variety of voices
and points of view within the show and
we hired sheen on the strength of his
talent as comedian and his impressive
audition for SNL we were not aware of
his prior remarks that have surfaced
over the past few days the language used
is offensive hurtful and unacceptable we
are sorry that we did not see these
clips earlier and that our vetting
process is [ __ ] and then he posted a
statement on his Instagram saying it
feels ridiculous for comedians to be
making serious public statements but
here we are I'm a comedian who was funny
enough to get SNL that can't be taken
away of course I wanted an opportunity
to prove myself at SNL but I understand
it would be too much of a distraction I
respect the decision they made I'm
honestly grateful for the opportunity I
was always a MADtv guy anyway shade this
is an interesting story because while
like this is the age that we're living
in if you so he's he um he is defending
himself by just being like it was a joke
it was a joke as a joke but he used like
the CH I and blank words like that's not
a joke like that is like he's he's using
the defensive like I'm a comedian like
we could say whatever you want when you
can like if you're making a joke that
might be off-color like okay that's what
comedians do and it might offend people
but to use a racial slur of a group
you're not a part of like that's not a
joke that's just weird yeah I guess I
haven't
too much into things that he said but
overall I just as one thing that he said
and he said overall I get the gist he
has offensive past comedic remarks which
you know they just need to depress it in
here is in his favor like there have
been a couple SNL comedians who have had
a stroke like Melissa be a listener
which I didn't even know until this came
up and they were citing other comedians
Trevor Noah
less we not forget and like I'm so big
I'm like yeah Trevor Noah should have
his platform he tweeted [ __ ] up chip
he apologized like give someone a chance
like same with Melissa Villasenor but
like now they're changing the rules
they're changing the rules and I don't
like that I I like consistency like the
rules should be the same for comedians
across the board whether it is to keep
them on or to cancel them but like
that's a great point
right so it just because then and it's
weird because I hadn't even heard of
Melissa Villasenor stuff nothing I'm
like so up in the communiques please but
like I like to pride myself you know and
you actually like us to know right and
it's just like the way that people treat
certain things like every cancellation
is treated differently like based on
based on who it is you know so I feel
like I don't know maybe people just
really like her but like her tweets were
just as offensive
ya know hers were terrible you send them
to every bird of bed right so like I
just don't understand why that's ok and
this is it yeah and the same goes for
Trevor Noah
even though Trevor Noah was really a
little bit before the age of
cancellation like he got in a little
early but that is an excellent point I
think there should be like a rule for
everyone you know and I can't imagine
this is the first time that SNL has run
into something like this because comedy
is so you know out there it's like the
only thing in in the world these days in
our current culture that's like
protected kind of so I'm sure this isn't
the first time they that they've run
into this allah melissa Villasenor
but um interesting and I also just think
like anyway I don't condone what what he
said at all but I think like the last
frontier of cancellation is is comedy
because you know like Dave Chappelle
says like these are jokes like they
shouldn't be you know looked at through
the lens of like a real speech regular
whatever but like SNL being you know one
of the biggest comedic mega powers in
the
tree choosing to fire this person I
think it says a lot and it's just like a
very present for other comedians because
now you you are gonna watch what you say
yeah and that does sometimes take away
from things being funny and I'm still
not saying I'm not saying I can do it
I'm just saying from an out like looking
at this analyzing what everyone has said
it's just not all I do not yeah you know
and it's not it's not the same treatment
for every comedian that's true
it's especially if it's all like with
with Trevor Noah
like okay he works at Comedy Central
that's a different network that I sent
out like I understand different
treatment but SNL just went through this
like there was a whole BuzzFeed article
about Melissa Villasenor when she got
hired in 2017 there was ton of really
[ __ ] weird REITs and I didn't even
hear about it until I just yesterday
yeah so so there should be equal
treatment I agree yeah and I mean I mean
this just sucks like as a comedian like
your entire life is like the dream for
every comedian is to be on SNL like
everyone both huge stars who were on SNL
and whom not on us and I'll have tried
out for us now it's like it really is
like the mecca of comedic
accomplishments and for him to have
gotten it and then get it taken away
like regardless of what you think of it
like [ __ ] sucks and also like these
comments aren't like so like someone had
to go digging you know through his
Twitter for like 10 years of tweets like
they're kind of recent which makes it
worse for him but it also makes it so
that like there's no excuse as to why
SNL did not know about this like writing
all these tweets came out I was like
well you figure like SNL knows is they
just hired their first Asian American
cast member like they obviously know
what they're doing I think that's why
maybe it got treated differently like
he's up here being announced next to an
asian-american it's in terrible taste
it's yeah it's not good but like it's
really crazy that they actually didn't
know cuz when I saw this I was like oh
well they obviously know and they chose
to you know forgive him and grow and
maybe there was even a discussion
amongst the cast members where everyone
says you know like we can forgive and
move on you know you know it should be
up to the new Asian cast member if he
can work with this guy then why can't we
all yeah it should be his call maybe it
was maybe yeah maybe it was I think he
has spoken out about it but I haven't
been
eating up with this too much until he
actually got fired and I was like yeah
no I was following it the past few days
just cuz like it's so person n't yeah
and I really was gonna see like if SNL
was gonna like stand firm and they're
comedians are protected vibe or not and
they didn't right and I just think it's
it's an interesting factoid you know
yeah like I don't really watch SNL I
don't have a horse in this race but it's
definitely an interesting precedent
after you the president had already been
set now we have a new precedent what's
that called uh new person I'm all about
precedents you know we're clearly when
the Sooners of the one with the
precedents but like in a movie or
something or something like legal
they're like well what's the precedent
you know well that's like lawyer ISM 100
101 and I don't know I just see like
lawyers and 101 is something you know
that we could look to in these times
yeah I guess not
different strokes for different well
it's so crazy because I just watched the
roast of Alec ball wouldn't I know you
didn't watch it but it was so [ __ ]
crazy like just so but you could find
something offensive with literally
transphobic misogynistic a racist like
the things they were saying up like
about Blake Griffin since Ken Jong cuz
he's interracial and he also has red
hair they were like you look like a
black guy who whose printer ran out of
ink like they were things they said
about [ __ ] the Caitlyn Jenner like
comedy judge and Comedy Central I feel
like is now like the last frontier of
people that like really push those kinds
of boundaries and yes it did make me
uncomfortable to watch but like people
thought it was funny so like whatever
like people are enjoying it cool so I'm
really surprised actually like that SNL
like they're there it's changing its
changing and I don't know I felt like
really hopeful after the Dave Chappelle
special because so many people enjoyed
it and I think what he was even like
even the most controversial things that
he said it's not necessarily that he
like agreed with like what he was saying
but he was just like defending his right
to say it right that's what the guy
actually yeah right I don't know if he
actually doesn't believe those boys but
like he's just like wants you to know
that he's allowed to say that he does it
right the point is that you don't have
to agree with me what I say but you have
to agree with my right to say right so
and I
with that mentality with that mentality
Peter
so but this doesn't yeah but at the same
time it's just like you know what she
like this is so easily avoidable like no
offense it's not like this guy Shane is
like the end-all be-all of SNL like they
really should have should have vetted
him and never hired him and and given
like this type of embarrassment on SNL
and on this guy Shane like there's tons
of really talented comedians who haven't
said racial slurs who would love the
opportunity to be on SNL so like this
whole thing really could have been
avoided all um I I agree with that and I
think it's a really honest and L the
fact that they didn't bet him and it's
on them for that and then to just be so
like spineless and yeah fire him just
because that's what everyone says now
like the pitchforks they can decide
who's on this and now any day now yeah
it sort of like we're never gonna be on
SNL right and I just definitely I don't
know and as much as they're comedians
who've never said anything offensive
like still we're all like human beings
nobody is perfect like everybody has
some [ __ ] that they're not proud of like
if we start like you could find actually
even in what you think a perfect
comedian like you can find fault in
anyone because you're still a [ __ ]
human being that's actually very true
so everyone's time will come see you
[ __ ] on the other side Wow okay
that's how we can Wicca fresh okay next
up Beyonce's team gives the finger to
the Emmys after homecoming shutout okay
I saw this a lot of thought I have a few
thoughts this weekend Beyonce's
critically acclaimed Netflix documentary
homecoming a film by Beyonce was shut
out of the 2019 creative arts Emmys
taking home none of the six awards for
which she was nominated or shut out they
were nominated no but it was a shutout
in terms of they lost a cross it was a
shutout would be not even being
nominated I just think that is when he
scored nothing making a game oh I guess
yeah
while Queen Bey has remained mama in the
matter key members of her crew took to
social media to share their
disappointment as publicists the event
Knowles sure post an Instagram video of
herself along with along with manager
Steve Pomona and other team members
throwing up the middle finger while
brushing off the evening so then one of
her cameraman went on a Twitter tirade
basically explaining how carpool karaoke
won for best like yeah make it said
James Corden's carpool karaoke just
one best technical direction a camera
taped to a windshield just won an Emmy
over this that wasn't his tweet he
retweeted it with laughing emojis and
then it has like footage of all the the
cameraman on like a Beyonce stage you
know but then he also did a few tweets
explaining how I held a heavy-ass camera
and walk backwards keeping these three
legends in frame while Dave had held a
carabiner on my pants to guide me oh and
I did it down
I didn't going down a set of stairs and
he explained how every 10 feet he would
tap him every two feet he would press
him right and how it was like a whole
system so while I totally agree that
carpool karaoke winning a creative Emmy
for anything cinematography is
incredibly stupid like they put a GoPro
in the front and what in the bass crazy
it's so stupid and such a [ __ ] and
honestly it's some you know what it is
it's just some sis crime let's James
Corden up here again but there is
something that I find so [ __ ] tacky
about people who complain like this the
most thing the thing that comes to mind
most similarly is like busy tonight like
[ __ ] you got 100 shows and like all you
do on your Instagram story and I was
complaining like you're in a million
articles being like I want more answers
as to why my show was canceled like so
does Roseanne okay like everyone does
like nobody wants to get cancelled so I
just I I hate that like that sense of
entitlement when it's like well yes
obviously I totally agree Beyonce
deserve to weigh but like that's not how
things work sometimes you know Floyd
were just being a sore loser like just
don't worry I agree like being a sore
loser like it's it really is an honor to
be nominated I think and it is so
outrageous that James Corden one it's so
outrageous but I would have never known
any of that if these people didn't tweet
this and I'm kind of glad that they did
because I'm like firmly on their side
and like this that is so [ __ ] like
whoever made that choice like should be
fired if these Emmys are ever gonna mean
anything right and I'm glad that I know
this that like they that the way that
they did this camera versus James Corden
and James Corden one you know yeah so
like while I agree I I think when you're
kind of like just really it is an honor
to be nominated for some people you you
you shut your mouth but like when you
really should have won I don't know I
don't know like I hear you and I totally
agree with them like I can't lie in
saying that I wouldn't do the same thing
like if I did something amazing and some
like weeny one but to me there's just
something so tacky about that that way
of going about your business
I completely agree but you get your but
let me also need to keep in mind that
all these people are not a reflection of
Beyonce I'm know what day she wasn't
even there no but I feel as though
beyond tan or publicist are like very
Taylor Swift II where it's like you know
you don't you don't speak on my behalf
without her permission sanctioning it so
I feel like she definitely was like go
off I don't care and and and I feel but
I I don't think it reflects on any of
them assume glad be honest I didn't show
up to a tough set sort of it no they
know like they tell the artists like if
they're gonna win or not and then then
they decided they can they do that I'd
like the American Music Awards I don't
think they do that at the Emmys they
definitely give him some sort of inkling
if she showed up and lost all six like
they would never allow for that kind of
embarrassment yeah ever really true also
she lost in five other categories but
they're not complaining about them
because it was warranted
they lost directing to Springsteen on
Broadway they lost live television event
to rent which actually cry abomination
about that what do you think about that
snatch that's the real crime that yeah
that's an abomination RuPaul's Drag Race
one for best costumes and FX's Fosse
burden one for musical direction
um and then Hannah Gadsby beat out
Beyonce for best writing with her
Netflix comedy special and than that I
just wanna I just want to address like
something someone in the comment said do
you guys want to be saying this if it
was Taylor and you guys know this I
totally disagree oh by the way I'm very
critical of Tara I always say a being a
good stand is not being a blind loyal
fan it's being able to point out
someone's flaws so excuse me Molly I
disagree with that I regardless of who
and I so I would be saying this about
anyone I think it is tacky to complain
about losing sorry the end yeah I do but
I'm in this instance I'm glad that they
did otherwise I wouldn't have I wouldn't
have known about the ten feet and the
taps and like I think it's pretty cool
so they're they're getting their own
story out their [ __ ] here no me neither
um I did yes beautiful like it's very
well done
and you know why I watched it because
skinny confidential puts it on her
Instagram um like two times in her
career Beyonce has cut her pay like
nearly in half for so she did it
at uber and they were supposed her money
and she yeah half the cash and half in
stock that's now worth like seven times
what it was originally worth and then
with Coachella she didn't take the pay
that everyone gets paid
she took a much less smaller cash and
then of like percentage of licensing of
her own performance because she knew she
was gonna do a Netflix seal now it's
worth like sixty million dollars so once
I saw the business of it I was like okay
I gotta watch it hmm that is interesting
I didn't know that thanks for the
factoid
okay next story speaking about making
money Kourtney Kardashian admits she
feels pressure from billionaire sister
Kylie Jenner did you see Kourtney
Kardashian on the real no I didn't but I
saw a quote card of the entire
experience on a news okay I think the
quotes are full of interesting factoids
Kourtney Kardashian is surrounded by
success whether it's her famous friends
or closest family members the Keeping Up
with the Kardashians star stays close to
some hard-working people
but when appearing on the season six
premiere of the real Kourtney was asked
if she feels pressure from her
billionaire sister Kylie Jenner she says
such a rude [ __ ] question they're
small it is but it was a quote probably
subconsciously it makes us feel like
when is it enough she shared on Monday
show and that's the thing I always think
to myself when is it enough because I
don't like missing out on certain things
like doing my kids homework or certain
after-school activities for different
things like that
she also said um about the success of
the show we didn't she kind of in this
interview was like a stream of conscious
where it's like it feels like she's
working out her thoughts as she say and
then I'm not really answering the
question no or just like she doesn't
even know how she feels about certain
things yes I said about keeping with her
dashians we didn't even think about it
we just hit the ground running and I
don't even know if that's the right
sentence we just kind of did it and it
happened so quickly and I don't even
think we even thought about it what
ultimately living your life in the
spotlight had some obstacles Kourtney a
minute she's had her moments where she
wishes her family wasn't in the public
eye you mean like every single episode
she said Chloe always tries to instill
in all of us this let's wake up and be
so grateful grateful that I'm filming in
my house are going to Chloe's house for
the day or filming with my sister or my
mom or my kids and so I do feel like we
all have our moments where we are like
quote I hate this or whatever
but at the current moment I am happy and
buried into my blessing
and feeling really good I've definitely
had my moments because life is short
okay that's hurting them saying I have
my moments can you go back to what she
said about Kylie I'm still understanding
she said does she feel pressure probably
subconsciously it makes us feel like
when is it enough when is what enough
like getting enough money being
successful and that's like because now
all of them are kind of like poppers
compared to Kylie we're like you know
compared to the average person like they
are so successful right and I kind of I
understand like that like I don't I
don't feel like Kylie doesn't even see
like how I need to make more and more
it's like that's a literally she just it
happened now it's like for the other
sisters like at one point they were all
super rich yeah now Kylie's in another
stratosphere that it kind of like puts
down what you know good American yeah
sound like everything that they're doing
cuz it's like oh we're not billionaires
like we have we're not six like oh so my
kids don't work yeah that's not what
you're supposed to do Kylie gets kid now
to like hey when she blames like her
lack of whatever I'm the fact that she's
a mom right like Kim now has more kids
than you can all have children
Chloe has like everyone is busy piano
and let's not forget about the millions
of women in America who are moms right
like Kourtney thinks she's the first mom
who ever walked this pond right because
she was the first mom in her family and
what's so crazy and I would probably be
like well you know she's probably just
like the mommy aslam but then Khloe like
chose to have her child live with Kim if
something were to god forbid ever
happened to her so it's like but those
kinds of conversations they were having
last season were so interesting like
really about like parenting styles and
when Kourt when Chloe said that like if
God forbid something happened she would
leave true with Kim like that was crazy
I know when Kourtney has always like put
the mom motherhood on her back right so
now these statements like hold less
weight I don't know I just thought it
was an interesting interview the fact
that like she's going to the REO like
they don't really do they don't do like
go to it express no only when they're
launching something like when Kim
launched Kim's she did the Today Show
and like Alice Marie Johnson stuff she
did like CNN but they're not really
mainstream media peeps because they have
their own platforms which are just as
big arguably bigger than the Today Show
yes yeah but it must be fun to like do
stuff like this sometimes or you always
go on Ellen yeah they have some deal
with Ellen like we won't ask you any
questions if you don't ask us
yeah I mean it's good for them and Jimmy
Fallon
yes and it makes for a fun time does you
want to know why also they and because
Jimmy Fallon and Ellen are both on NBC
and then they also film Keeping Up with
the Kardashians like backstage at
Ellen's so it's good synergy because
it's all NBC you content Bravo
he is on NBC you so I think it's a
synergy thing totally okay next up a
little more Kardashian news Brad Pitt
says Kanye West Sunday service is quote
really special Brad Pitt is giving Kanye
West Sunday service a glowing review
after recently attending the soulful
celebration quote I think he's doing
something really special there he told
Entertainment Tonight on Monday it's a
pure celebration of life and people it's
really delightful that sounds like
greatest showmen a celebration of
humanity Brad Pitt has been doing like
so much press like who's in GQ now he's
we're gonna entertain you tonight was
not Astra oh no one like him like he's
like I saw those GQ pics I was like damn
daddy what else like what are you doing
I read a blind because Eddie's back on
Instagram making my life so much easier
to see the blind that Kourtney
Kardashian Brad Pitt are smoking Wow
he's coming
maybe maybe Brad Pitt could get the
stick out of Kourtney Kardashian's ass I
actually do it it's it I actually think
that's a great pairing for her of course
oh my god I would die I would die
I can't believe and he says that Brad
Pitt in corticon or [ __ ] oh my god
I'm obsessed I I ship I alter
oh my god that would be crazy really
hope that's really crazy
oh now explain why he's coming to Sunday
service yeah hey doll so you could just
go to Sunday service because you think
it's beautiful like I'm Jimmy sure glad
I want to go that's like what a
beautiful couple
I know this makes me if this is true I
love Courtney no by the way same because
I love with Brad Pitt me too we've
spoken on the show how we think he is a
true P drama and a real gentleman and
he's just like the hottest man alive
he's so talented and like yeah he seems
like a good guy
oh my god I would I would die Nasir
honestly matching me today and it's very
age-appropriate like she's 40 now I
think it's like low-key perfect I gotta
say I need insider Intel like oh yeah
Antti 4 verse or yeah because I don't
want to get my hopes up because that
it's just like too beautiful but Kendall
had revealed on Jimmy Fallon that Brad
Pitt had been to Sunday service quote a
couple times but she avoided meeting him
because she's too much of a big fan and
quote gets nervous I I could see Kendall
Jenner's like number one Stan being for
red pay you know yeah look she reserves
that fangirl only for Brad Pitt yeah
she's a good cool girl but when I can't
know what grades yeah but like Oh break
it love that [ __ ] but nobody liked his
beyond standing Brad Pitt you know no no
no one actually watch that interview
with me I'm saying that and she was like
they always said don't meet your heroes
your heroes so I just couldn't meet him
yeah but if he's four sisters man she's
gonna have to meet him well okay look I
get ahead of ourselves it's just
something to think about I really like
I'm pawtucket like down the line they
date for five years like is he ever
gonna be on an episode with the
Kardashian Kanye is yeah this should
know but like Brad Pitt nothing is
impossible nothing is impossible
truly like Kardashian's it's that's
where it's at like right like that's the
moment I don't think anyone would have
ever looked down on like all of that
more than Kanye yeah but if it's if it's
cool enough for Kanye like it's cool
enough for Brad Pitt wow I'm just really
I'm like rethinking everything like - I
love Courtney no no I love Courtney I
wish her like I was having a but only
with Brad Pitt from like Eunice to read
Pitt oh so what was Eunice at her
birthday I mean you're like being an Ida
and then she obviously had a
conversation with him in addition to 40
other people you know I was like
freaking out like this whole week and
then I woke up saying I'm just feeling
fine you know it's a breakdown today in
Venice it just like not worry about like
my life would be you know
yeah she's kids by the way I realized
something crazy cuz I watched Alice
right after yesterday and Cortney is 10
years younger than DeAndre Simmons it's
that weird no that kind of make sense I
don't know I feel like Kourtney just
seems so much younger in tanjur this
seems so much older
well I've always been surprised the
Kardashians have old always been older
than I thought they were like when we
were like obsessed with them in high
school they were like almost 30 and they
were like socialites you just assumed
they were like 21 you know they've
always been like a generation above what
I thought they were yeah especially
Kourtney right and forever I thought
Chloe was the oldest look before I
really knew them like when they were
just like a bunch of sisters like in
halter dresses like
I didn't I didn't for one second think
that Courtney was jealous I thought she
was the youngest maybe because she was
like Kourt Chloe was so tall yeah so
just like Chloe's the youngest the
oldest then Kim then Courtney but it was
literally the OPP's I feel like that's
how people feel about us like it takes
them a while to rely said I'm older than
you
oh really yeah unless maybe now they
know the more you know I'm just so I
thought were this tanjit turn I'm so
obsessive this duo like Wow Wow and
honestly to me like that is that's like
Megan and Harry status of like two like
GG and Tyler like different University
three universes but Sunday's service
look Jesus bringing people together it's
a celebration of humanity it's what
Jesus would have wanted a different
critic might have called it a
celebration of humanity what's that from
good job okay fifth and final story a
little streaming news because the
streaming words you guys these are like
the new late-night Wars is the streaming
wars and also the hard seltzer wars the
hard seltzer wars are poppin yeah
but netflix has acquired the global
streaming rights to Seinfeld Wow Netflix
Netflix has fired back in the battle for
popular network sitcoms by landing the
global streaming rights to Seinfeld as
part of a deal with Sony Pictures
Television which controls distribution
of the iconic TV show Netflix will offer
180 episodes of Seinfeld in the US and
two it's 151 million subscribers
throughout the world when the five-year
pact takes effect in 2021 the company's
announced so they are losing friends and
the office because other streaming
networks but they're getting Seinfeld
okay here's what Netflix needs to get in
order to really like submit me as a
subscriber even though I used someone
else's subscription I need the nanny
oh yeah I need the simple life and I
need desperate awesome are you sure the
simple life is on Hulu it's on prime
alright you could buy it on Amazon and I
need them to bring back toe trust the B
in apartment 23
oh I agree like they're just letting
series go left and right and they're not
you know it understanding the importance
of Desperate Housewives you know yeah
and Hannah Montana yeah yes like took
them on yeah
genuinely wish I cared about Seinfeld
but I'm happy for the people who do you
know what I'm actually looking forward
to this because when I know exactly like
Seinfeld so now what I'll be playing in
our apartment in 2021
um but also like it I've never watched a
whole episode and I do think I might
like it because I love Larry David I
love curves so like if I love that sense
of humor maybe I'll like Seinfeld yeah
you might like curb is without question
much better than Seinfeld like and I
know Seinfeld is regarded as like yeah
but honestly it's really honestly an
annoying show and don't come for me
because like and it's like our type of
humor aside rides you as humor like I
really like don't love Seinfeld like
obviously if it's on I will watch it
like I will I get more than cheers you
know yeah but it's no it's no yeah it's
no curb oh okay yeah no everyone's just
so annoying on those shows like I
remember one half of an episode I saw
was when like the girl like me picked up
juju fruits at the on her way to see her
friend in the hospital and he was and
they were like you picked up two two
fruits and like you just like keep
talking to higher picked on each other
and was silly they just like repeat the
same you it's like no no shade but it's
really just not a funny joke hey kind of
one I want to give I do want to give you
try because like it's working you are
weird you might like it like you will
not really yeah but I don't know if I'll
even if I there's things about it that I
find funny like I can't stand that
sitcom format with the laughter and I'm
sorry I have an announcement to tell you
something very important that I just
recently found out about friends um it
is filmed in front of a live studio
audience that is not a laugh track no I
know but when I say laugh track I mean
like laughter like I know that they
don't press but they hold up the signs
laugh I just don't like laughter period
okay like oh I get it like Jonah
interrupts it's really annoying
I find it doesn't bother me up notice
that laughs it did uh-huh but it's just
like it's so annoying to me I know that
it's live and to me that's the same
thing live track live audience either
way they're being forced to laugh and
it's so annoying okay um let me hold up
a sign laugh
like I can't fake laughs whatever let's
recap all the television that was on
last night but before I do that I have
to let you know that today's episode is
brought to you by Vistaprint the most
important time is now the importance of
feeling professional polished and
prepared when it counts is right now for
small business owners or people who
produce their own podcast being plugged
in and prepared when an opportunity
comes up as crucial those moments happen
all the time they're happening now and
having a business card that shows how
professional you are in your pocket
ready to hand out is the first step to
making something happen your next big
opportunity is coming right now and
we're here to help you to own them out
with free shipping on any business card
in any quantity from vistaprint choose
whatever style finished shape or paper
you like and get free shipping and
because you can pick the colors fonts
designs and images it means you can
create something as unique and
compelling as your business plug your
information in logo into hundreds of
fresh designs tailored to your type of
company or upload your own original
layout you can even upgrade to a unique
touch like rounded corners order and
receive your cards with free economy
shipping you could feel good knowing
that vistaprint uses only carefully
sourced inks and responsibly sourced
paper stocks vistaprint wants you to be
able to own the now in any situation
which is why our listeners will get free
shipping on all business cards any style
any quantity just go to vistaprint.com
and enter promo code toast to for free
shipping on all business cards and style
any quantity limited time offer only now
at vistaprint.com use the promo code
toast - that is the promo code toast
followed by the number to your support
of our show you supporters show when you
support our sponsors at Vistaprint com
promo code toast - get them these cars
yeah ok a week at first tall girl so I'm
a tall girl at the end so I can walk out
sure sure I do Dancing with the Stars so
I know you don't watch I don't really
watch either but I just decided to take
it on because I really wanted to see
Hannah Brown and I really wanted to see
Lauren Lena and to be honest like this
show the way it's produced like it is a
billion dollar shell we have a new set
like they got it all covered even though
like the cameraman kept dropping the
cameras during people's perform that was
weird I couldn't [ __ ] see anything
here were my top performers it's not so
easy that's why Beyonce's cameraman very
true here were my top four top
performers Lauren Elena
I thought they judged her really like
harsh and and almost like unfair but
she still did really well I watch Hannah
Browns she was really good surprisingly
but she's like a young able-bodied girl
like it doesn't shock me that she has
rhythm you know justice for Allie Brooke
who got literally the worst she was at
the bottom with like Lamar when she's
the most talented dancer on that stage
they were dancing her as if she was like
in a ballroom competition like in you
know like in silver lining that's why
they were so hard on her because she is
a dancer so the judges judge everyone
this same Jackie I couldn't agree more
like it was so unfair like the there's a
woman I don't know her name Mary
something Mary Wilson who was one of the
original Supremes and she's 75 and a
half and she looks amazing and she you
know it's really impressive like how she
but she was she's like in the top four
and I swear to you should move she
didn't move and they were really judging
her based on like just her being a
legend and like I don't know her being
like in shape for her age I guess but
like she was worse than them are oh damn
I'm sorry her a few extra points like
you know agree but you don't mean being
away from other people like if Allie
Burke was great like she should get a
ten but and you shouldn't penalize her
but like yet maybe give someone a little
bonus here and there if they're you know
really defying the odds but like it
should be the same scale it should be
blind judging yes so the only part of
the show I don't really like Stan or get
behind is the judging first of all I
find all three judges to be so thirsty
in a no angler no get way so the guy who
has the microphone is him Andy Tom host
Tom huh he's like they're their lives so
he's trying to like push it through I'm
like these judges cannot get enough
camera time like they are so [ __ ]
thirsty like I find them all to be so
annoying and their judging is off like
they should really leave it to America I
don't think we need the judges I'm not
gonna lie like I think that as the
season progresses like judges just
become irrelevant yeah absolutely don't
quote me on that but no and she would be
fair I think totally um also someone who
really came out of left field and really
surprised me was Ray Lewis I didn't
really know who he was before I said who
he was he's like a really big deal and
he was having so much fun with it he
really like was loose and he was letting
himself go and I really thought he did a
great job and now we need to talk about
the Sean Spicer at all okay Andy Cohen
said the funniest thing I watch happens
live being like that all the Queens who
work in
wardrobe and hair and makeup we're
getting their revenge on Sean Spicer
because what they made him wear was
honestly like this lime-green shining
ruffled shirt and these tight white
pants like everything was ill-fitting
but I have to say like he was a good
sport like he knew everyone there hated
him and it was like honestly really
awkward like honest but he was just
honestly having a good time I thought he
was a really good sport like the judges
were kind of mean to him but like he
really was just like laughing having a
good time and honestly I commend like
that that is a sense of bravery like to
be out like it was really an a stance it
wasn't terrible is pretty good for like
the guys were pretty bad I don't know it
I like Lamar Odom my belly next for him
just cause like I genuinely can't
imagine what it feels like to just be in
that situation where you know like
everyone here it was like almost there
was all this outrage when he got cast
like honestly he never should have done
it but he's doing it and he's like
sticking with the decision like he's
selling that cream shirt get him down
the green shirt would really found the
drums and the green turn I was just like
this is not like the shirt mates you
know like I like this shirt accepted
like he's really embracing like whatever
but like you guys the shirt was all
whole like and him with the long sleeves
and the drum you know outfits are like
no canopy's outfit was so [ __ ] rock
head ID she looks amazing but I outfits
are unfair I want to say what Allie
Brooke wore and what had a be war so
[ __ ] cute figure skater was it for
Lauren Alaina in the ugly green dress
with the brown belt
yeah but that looks like a Shrek cosplay
do you think they have some say I think
they don't just get put it all of course
not they didn't have any say yes do I
think that they do you do yes
oh I thought for sure like to Sean
Spicer like I had to wear that shirt no
I'm sure like if you they were like this
is [ __ ] hideous I'm not wearing it
there won't be like we're gonna make
these things I think that they get say
they're not gonna wear something that
they don't feel comfortable and the show
isn't about like you know making people
uncomfortable
other than Sean Spicer but I think the
week one will like this would be his
worst week because now Pete like oh
they're over the hump of like right and
introducing him like humanizes people
you know look you're watching them for
two hours straight like they're in the
background of every scene like it's
honestly such I don't think he would
like be on that show
it's so awkward yeah
like see when I was watching me I just
kept thinking about you being on there
we [ __ ] killin they go to commercial
break you would kill him the dancing but
they go to commercial break and they're
like all right Ali Brooke is up next and
Ali burger standing there and all the
contestants have to stand behind her bag
yeah like that's so uncomfortable I got
her and I think he would [ __ ] hate
I'm not gonna lie that is my worst
nightmare
oh that's the whole thing yeah dance for
one minute why I couldn't go on The
Bachelor because when you have to like
run around the house right scream like
Colton like I would I would literally
never get death um James and I we came
out on top with the highest score he was
pretty good he has five kids and they're
all blond and I didn't really think he
was like so amazing but to me it's a lot
easier to be a guy with a high score
that to be a girl with a high score
because the dance is really revolves
around the girl so if your partner is a
professional girl like it's a little bit
easier to distract from the fact that
you're just standing there but yeah the
girl really carries the whole
performance and so that's why I really
am just not over Ali Brooke no that's
what I was saying last night that it's
like for a guy all you have to is hold
out your arm and then they do their
friend you with their own strength or
whatever when you're a girl that's not a
pro you have no idea how to do that's
the other one looks better after all of
it who are you rooting for
I mean I'm rooting for how to be
actually I actually think that she could
win and also her partner Alan he's like
one of the only single ones because by
the way I don't know if you know I was
like the romance is but half of them are
all married to each other
that I chose but Alan was Alexis wrens
partner last season and they were dated
so like he's open to shoot you think
that Hannah he's Jewish too oh do you
have Hannah and Alan are gonna see I
don't like actually I think they could
smooch but I don't think that they're
gonna date I don't know I mean I shall
read a lot of love
I am very forlorn Elena but like part of
me also wants to relive us to win like I
honestly to study was such a good sport
and like he was a good dancer so he is
my beau I'm actually gonna vote like a
loser I'm gonna vote like a loser too
and I'm just gonna keep like voting for
like for everyone like I'm not just only
voting for one person and then as it
whittles down
I'll choose I'll choose a horse in this
race yeah okay you they have to earn me
your boat yeah um now you can go cuz
we're gonna talk about tall girl okay
um your face out guys maybe if you bring
me a snack like if you see one shelter
gravel great work today senator tall
girl is the new movie on Netflix it's
the youngest young adult
romance and it's about a girl who's tall
um and actually fun fact I saw she's
really tall but she was wearing like
stilts in her shoes also the way that
the camera was working was like making
her look even tall her and everyone else
look even shorter Sabrina carpenter like
we needed more of her in the movie she
was so funny and like she was like
shallow but like nah no she was a good
Saint was a good sister I'm like she
knew what was important like yes she was
like all into the pageantry and the baby
she would have trapped it all in a
heartbeat fear says no I thought like I
really could have used more character
development on Sabrina carpenters part
like not just her walking around in the
dress no I could I loved the dress she
looks so so she it's just like such a
great like character in a film like
because you you want to like her cuz
she's just like perfect and then she's
also good on the inside yeah but the
tall girl okay so honestly a part of me
knew that she wasn't gonna end up with a
foreign exchange student but I
definitely didn't see him like being
such a [ __ ] loser coming like I
didn't see that coming like what a
wiener I know it kind of frustrated me
because it was like a little bit too
much of a jump cuz oh by the way I
totally got it like when you're in high
school and you finally hang out with the
cool kids like you will do and say
anything to keep herself being cool no
he was finally ended up Franklin no I
understand why he like blew her off and
and he was like you know starting to
feel himself but like when he in that
video when he like lied completely like
that was a bit of a jump cuz I thought
he was a decent guy but I agree but then
even like the the little one who she
winds up with my uncle Berg he was such
a [ __ ] friend for so long and like he
also got caught up with the popular kids
like okay so he did the right thing once
but like he also encouraged for our an
exchange boy to embrace his popularity
but some people could see that as an act
of like a romance you know I know but
like if you loved it like he loves tall
and like if you love her and like you
know how can you like that would crush
her how do you want to see the person
you love crush you know when he was
doing that in the bunk bed I was like oh
man you're [ __ ] evil bro but then I
don't know he really is selfish but you
know what I thought she was being a
[ __ ] in the beginning like he is such a
nice guy all you do is sit and complain
that nobody likes you when there's
literally a boy who has such a nice
house sitting in front of you telling
you that he likes you pink door you
could take pictures in front of like
yeah I could not stress enough how much
I love that they filmed it in New
Orleans it was such an interesting
backdrop and like all the houses were
like historic and beautiful I thought it
was I've never seen a movie set in New
Orleans
I thought it was great no and it was
like the even her house is like the
outside looks so different than the
inside just from like a home-baked
horror standpoint it was so interesting
Jenny
SoDo luck I want to read it to you
someone made the greatest call why did
this is from Jordan Potts why do they
not cast Joe Josie was a tall girl she's
tall she was born she's actually 15 yes
I thought that girl was really cute and
pretty um also the best character was
her best friend who she was an [ __ ]
too I know and I'm just like so glad
that the friend was into fashion but she
didn't wind up making her something
custom Oh same and by the way I like
that they think Oh first of all the
parents were so perfectly cast what was
the dad from it was bothering me so much
I don't know but we can hook it up and
then Angela Kinsley who is
what's-her-name from the office yeah was
the mom she was hilarious
I thought the parents were really fun oh
my god when you go to search tall girl
you got like tall girl Heights Steve
Zahn oh he's from a lot of stuff look
again it's even like Honey I Shrunk the
Kids no no um hold on it was bothering
me angel makes what you're thinking of
he's from daddy daycare but that's not
it no saving Silverman Stuart Little
wait what saving Silverman that sounds
so fun it's a good movie he saw someone
riding in cars with boys none of this is
coming back maybe he's like an actor
that I know no I know what you're
thinking someone also just left a
comment that we both had the same
thought that the movie really reminded
us of Dublin and ER Burgess combined
yeah it's the same set for the pageant
room you know no and it reminded me of
that we'll come back to what the dads
from um it reminded me of it because it
was like both of those characters had
such a bad attitude when it was like
they were they felt like the world was
treating them a certain way when it was
like no everyone's kind of like nice
said that's where the Sierra Burgess
like she was so [ __ ] mean to her mom
and like her mama loved her for who she
was no matter what yeah and like with
dumpling like she was mean to everyone
because she thought everyone was
treating her some type of way but like
everyone was really nice to her but I do
feel like with tall girl like there was
more examples of like bullying and Togo
really wasn't meaning to a lot of people
like I thought you know forgiving even
going out with Swisher or whatever is it
yes yeah but she was just like so hard
like her
herself and that was like frustrating
because I just wanted to be like you're
beautiful and you're tall who cares yes
I let you come to that realization
herself yeah like that is not a problem
to have three years but you're gonna be
at New York Fashion Week and all these
losers are gonna be stuck in New Orleans
I know and it's like even when you know
when models they talk about how they
were bullied growing up cuz they were so
tall
yeah like okay like tiny violins I live
so I guess it was reminding me of that
where it's like I just don't like you're
tall and you're beautiful like how could
people make fun of you yeah when
Dunkleman like first of all bought her
the shoes and like woke up in the bed
that was like so cute and then when they
finally understood what the belt crate
was for like that was really cute I
would say like I ship I'd like domina I
kind of felt like they were gonna be
together the whole time because for the
most part he had pure good intentions
and like yes he didn't do everything
right but you young men in love yeah yep
he helped I agree I actually didn't know
that they were gonna be together the
whole time cuz like he was really
letting popular he gets his head and I
actually thought the gluten-free girl
was a perfect match for him yeah she was
nice yeah and she like loved him for who
he was it's so much in common like I
just thought he was gonna end up with
her and then tall girl would be like
well I let the greatest thing go I feel
like he kind of has like a fetish I
actually think that might be a good call
like his obsession with her was so weird
and he is yeah she wasn't even nice to
him like what where did it cut like he
was just obsessed with the fact that she
was tall like honest things like a
fetish movie honestly if you look at it
from that way it's a sick [ __ ] you
shouldn't be for children oh my god yeah
it's especially made that the drug was
so yeah Wow yeah he's got some [ __ ] to
work out and I really was like a loving
tall girl and oh my god I need thank you
someone just reminded me who the dad is
from Steve's an was on friends he
married Phoebe who was the ice dancer
thank you okay
all and although a good movie like we
haven't had a good young adult Netflix
film since like to all the boys I love
before like they tried to make it happen
with Sierra Burgess chunk you know like
I like them all I keep giving them like
even falling in love very sweet very
cute like I'm loving them all some
aren't as good as others but it's still
enjoyable it's like a hallmark movie
like you should see some of the [ __ ] I
watch you know I'm sure
compared to that like all those
ciara Burgess let's take more literally
the worst movie ever not even we got um
Christine process oh that's true and
she's in the society yeah and isn't
what's-his-face in it no uh sentence
yeah but they've been throwing him and
[ __ ] just to baby now make us think it's
good yeah they put it in like dirty
movies since his original they think
he's like the key to the youths and it's
like he's on no nothing is gonna make
swipe to good movie nothing oh my god
that wasn't dumbest thing Mo's app calls
literally the worst [ __ ] woman's it
was saying like as your tall girl it is
hell and I believe that like I I could
feel like and there's nothing you can do
about your height like I feel that but I
feel like in high school like everyone
has something about them that makes them
feel like a pariah but really for the
most part it's just you and your
insecurities yeah like I used to be so
insecure about the color of my hair like
high school was torture for me but it
wasn't as there because people were
torturing me it was just like I felt
that way I'm so uncomfortable in my own
skin and like so many high schoolers are
you know so it's hard to like watching
this and don't be like cry beautiful you
know right but I'm someone could say the
same thing about you right but it's like
no I'm a freak
yeah thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning Justin
millennial Morning Show as a reminder we
will have march out very soon so start
thinking about that also I'm heading to
Vancouver Seattle and Portland this
weekend tickets available girls nutjob
comments quittin gonna be a grand old
time the morning ptosis and Lenny I'm
morning shall we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so feel free to give this video
a thumbs up and subscribe we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found that's iTunes Spotify
stitcher Public Radio literally anywhere
um thank you so much we love you
grabbing the job jackieo problem see you
tomorrow home do you
you